ALEX PASSOS: My name is Alex.
And I'm here to tell
you about something cool
that we've been working
on in the TensorFlow team
for the past few months.
This is mostly work done by
Google Brain in Cambridge.
And I'm here presenting because,
well, I'm not in Cambridge.
So this project is
called AutoGraph.
And what it is, is
essentially, a Python compiler
that creates TensorFlow
graphs for you.
So I'm sure, since you
walked into this room,
you probably used
TensorFlow before.
And you might have some
idea about how it works.
And the way it works,
under the hood,
is you build this graph to
represent your computation.
And here, there is a
multiply, an add, and a relu.
This is a very simple
neural network.
And the nice thing about
having a TensorFlow graph
is that once you
have this graph,
you can deploy it to a server.
You can train it on a TPU.
You can run it on your mobile
phone with TensorFlow.js.
You can run it on
a Raspberry Pi.
There's all sorts of
things you can do with it.
You have-- we have compilers
that take these graphs
and produce
highly-optimized code
for all sorts of platforms.
The downside of this
graph is that you end up
writing code like this, which
you see five lines of code,
one of which has the
actual computation that you
want to run.
And in case you're too far
to read, it's the fourth one.
Everything else is boilerplate.
And some of this boilerplate
is easy to deal with,
like these place holders.
But some of the
boilerplate is not.
For example, if you want
a TensorFlow model that
has control flow
inside the model,
you have to take your
mental idea of what code
you want to write,
which probably looks
like the example on the left,
where you have a Python "if,"
and turn it into the code
on the right, which is what
we need to generate a graph.
And the reason why
we need this is
that our computation graph,
because it can be put on a TPU,
and put on a phone,
and run independently
of the code that
produced this graph,
has to have information
about both branches
of your conditional.
So we need to somehow tell
TensorFlow everything that
could possibly happen
in this program.
And so you end up
with code that's
very redundant in this way.
And we have answers for this.
And we're working hard
to make your life easier
if you want to use TensorFlow.
One project I've
spent a lot of effort
personally on is
eager execution.
And the idea of
eager execution is
to make your life
easier by saying,
you don't have to
do graphs at all.
And you can take
this idea fairly far.
But eventually, you
hit some limits.
Right?
If you're-- with eager
execution enabled,
you have a very
intuitive interface.
You just write Python code.
You use Python
control flow, Python
infrastructures-- all the things
you're already familiar with.
And it's nice.
But you don't get this automatic
parallelism and distribution
and scale that Frank
was telling you
about with all the TPU
pods, because you still
have to run Python code.
And processors aren't
getting faster.
And Python is inherently
single-threaded.
We have a few ways of
getting around this.
Like, from eager
execution, we have
defun-- this primitive that
lets you build little graphlets
and run them.
So within that graphlet,
you have all the performance
of graph mode.
But you still can have eager
execution in your outer loop.
We can also have
py_func, which lets
you have full graph code
that can run on clusters
of multiple GPUs,
but with eager code
in the middle that's doing some
complicated control flow stuff.
And these tools are useful.
Both defun and py_func
are differentiable.
They run on all
sorts of devices.
They give you a
lot of flexibility.
But it's a little
unsatisfying that you have
these seams in your program.
And you need to think about,
what's going to be a graph?
What's not going to be a graph?
What if we could do
better than this?
And AutoGraph is this tool
that we've been working on,
in the Google Brain
Cambridge office, that
tries to do better than this.
And what it lets you do is
write eager-style, Python code
and have a compiler turn
this into the boring, very
complicated, graph-style code.
Because if you think
with me for a second,
if you look at the
transformations that
need to happen to turn
the code on the left
into the code on the right,
that looks like something
that can be automated.
And AutoGraph is,
indeed, the thing that
automates this transformation.
It's pretty easy to use now.
It's in TensorFlow.contrib.
And when 2.0 comes out,
it will be in Core.
You just import
AutoGraph from contrib.
And you decorate your function
with autograph.convert.
Then, when you call
it, under the hood,
AutoGraph will generate and
run this more complicated code
for you.
And these are not
academic concerns.
There's a lot of code out there
that has control flow in it.
So for example,
the implementation
of dynamic RNN in
TensorFlow is very hard
to read if you're not familiar
with how TensorFlow works.
But I can write one,
here, in the slide.
And it's pretty easy.
If you squint, you
have a "for" loop
that loops over my sequential
data, applies an RNN cell,
and has some logic in
it to mask the outputs,
because the different
sequences in the minibatch
can have different lengths.
But this is not--
this is 11 lines of code.
There's no magic here.
But if you run it
through AutoGraph,
you get the actual code that
you see inside tf.dynamic_rnn,
which is substantially
harder to read.
And not just RNNs--
in this-- I mean, this RNN
is a basic building block
that we use in all sorts of
sequence-to-sequence models,
when we're generating text,
when we're generating images,
when we're turning
data into other data.
And this is just one
example of this kind
of control-flow-rich programs
that you often want to write,
but that writing in
normal Graph TensorFlow
can be more painful
than it needs to be.
So what AutoGraph supports is
a subset of the Python language
that covers what I hope
is what you most need
to run in a TensorFlow program.
So we can do print.
And I don't know how
many of you have ever
failed to use tf.print,
because I do about once a week.
It's really hard, right?
Also tf.assert-- it's very
easy to have your assertion
silently dropped in the void.
AutoGraph is also composible.
So you can have
arbitrary Python code,
with classes and functions
and complicated call trees.
And it will turn the whole
thing into a graph for you.
You can have nested control
flow, with breaks and continues
and all sorts of stuff.
And we can make that work.
And we're still working
on it to make it better.
So another nice
example, I think,
to visualize what AutoGraph is
actually doing, is using what
has been unanimously decided
to be the best interview
question in the history of
humanity, which is FizzBuzz--
this thing where you
loop over the numbers.
And you print "Fizz" for some of
them, "Buzz" for some of them,
"FizzBuzz" for some of them.
And otherwise, you just
increment your counter
and print the number.
And you can see this is like
10 lines of Python code,
pretty straightforward.
But you should try to turn
it into in TensorFlow code.
And we ran it through
AutoGraph, because I'm too
lazy to write this code myself.
It's not pretty.
And if you think this
is it, this is not.
This is it [LAUGHS].
So this all looks nice.
But I think you would be remiss
to believe me if you didn't
understand how this works.
So I want to spend a
few minutes and tell you
what we're actually doing
to make this possible.
And there's many ways
of conceptualizing this.
But I think, really,
the core of AutoGraph
is we're extending the notion
of what's possible with operator
overloading.
And I don't know if you're
familiar with operator
overloading.
It's a feature in Python
that lets you customize
a little bit of the language.
And we use this
heavily in TensorFlow.
So for example, when you
write c = a * b in TensorFlow,
we don't actually run the
Python multiplication operator.
What actually runs is
the thing on the right,
c = tf.multiply(a, b).
And the way we turn one--
the code on the left
into the code on the right is
by having this Tensor class,
where a and b are tensors.
This Tensor class defines this
_ _nul_ _ method, which Python,
then, when it sees the
operator, it rewrites to a call
to the multiply method.
And then, we can use
this multiply method
to make whatever code we want
run when you type the star.
And this is pretty
straightforward
and shouldn't be
big of a surprise.
But what Python doesn't
let you do is this.
There's no way in
Python to override
the behavior of
the "if" operator
to run some code
you want to run.
So ideally, if Python
let us override _ _if_ _,
we would be able to make all
sorts of graph rewrites that
take control flow
into consideration.
Sadly, we can't.
So what we're trying
to do, really,
is overwrite the syntax
that Python doesn't
let us override the syntax.
And the way we do this is we
read the Python abstract syntax
tree of your code.
We process it using Python's
[INAUDIBLE] modules.
And we just run a bunch of
standard compiler passes.
We rewrite loops so that
they have a single exit.
We capture all the
variables that you assign
in loops and conditionals.
We unify the variables that
you mutate in either branch
of a conditional.
We do all these
boring transformations
that need to happen, so that we
can take the code that you want
to write, that has
advanced control flow,
into the code that TensorFlow
wants you to write.
And if you've been
following me so far,
you might have a question
in your head, which
is that, if you've written
TensorFlow program--
AutoGraph didn't exist.
You look at your code.
It's full of "ifs," and
"while" loops, and "for" loops,
and things like that.
And you probably don't
want any of those things
to end up in a graph,
because a lot of this
is just configuration.
You're choosing what
optimizer to use.
Or you're choosing how many
layers your network has.
And you have-- these things are
very easy to express in loops.
But you might think
that if we rewrite
every loop and
conditional in your code
to be a TensorFlow
loop or conditional,
you're going to end up with
all those things in your graph.
And you don't.
And the way you don't
is pretty clever,
which is that we use
Python's dynamism
to help us instead of hurt us.
So when we rewrite the--
in our operator overloaded logic
with _ _if_ _ and _ _while_ _,
we don't call tf.cond.
We call something
that, in spirit, looks
like this function, where
if you pass at a tensor,
it runs tf.cond.
But if you pass at something
that's not a tensor,
it runs a normal
Python conditional.
So if you have code that's
not TensorFlow code,
and you run it
through AutoGraph,
we should preserve its meaning,
preserve its semantics.
So it should be safe.
And you can trust
that it will only
change the behavior of code that
you want the behavior to change
because it's doing something
that you're not allowed to do,
like have an "if" that depends
on the value of a tensor
at graph build time.
And to get there, we had to do
a lot of work, and a lot of work
that, as I was saying,
is the same work
that any compiler has to do.
We figure out what
variables we're using.
We rewrite things in a single
static assignment form,
so that we can handle
things like breaks,
and continues, and breaks
inside "ifs," and functions
with multiple return points.
Because the core TensorFlow
syntax doesn't let
you have those things.
But thankfully, that is
just syntactic sugar.
It's just simple transformations
that you can do on
the-- you can remove all
these features by doing
simple transformations
on the code that
do not affect its meaning.
And in AutoGraph, we do those
transformations for you.
So you can really write the
code that you want to write.
And we'll try to run
it as best as we can.
So we do break and continue,
inline "if" expressions.
We're working on
list comprehensions.
We have basic support
for "for" loops.
We let you do multiple
return statements.
We also de-sugar "for"
loops into "while"
loops because we can't--
TensorFlow-- there's
no tf.for loop.
But AutoGraph implements
tf.for loop for you.
And a good way to think
about what we're doing here
is that we're adding
another stage of processing
in your computation.
Right now, if you're using
TensorFlow from graphs,
you write graph-style
code in Python.
You give this to the TensorFlow
runtime to execute it.
What AutoGraph lets
you do is write
eager-style code in Python,
which is imperative,
which has no control
dependencies,
and all these things that you
don't want to think about.
And AutoGraph will go
turn this eager-style code
into Graph-style code for
you and then hand this
over to TensorFlow runtime.
And again, if you're at all
skeptical at this point--
you're like, well, I've
used TensorFlow before.
I've seen what the error
messages look like.
If you're adding another
layer of computation,
is that going to become
even harder than it already
is, to debug what's going on?
And the good news is
that it doesn't have to.
So if you think about it,
we have these three stages
of your computation now.
We have, AutoGraph is
processing your code.
That's stage 0.
Then stage 1 is, your code is
being run to generate a graph.
And stage 2 is, TensorFlow
is executing your code
to actually do the
thing you want.
If you get an error in stage
0, when AutoGraph is processing
your code, you'll
just get a stack
trace that points to AutoGraph.
You file a bug
against us in GitHub.
And they'll fix it.
If we get an error
during stage 1,
which is the code
that you wrote--
well, the code that you wrote,
that AutoGraph transformed
into code that you don't
know how to read because it's
full of that extra boilerplate
that we didn't want
to deal with in
the first place--
and you get an error
there, we actually
rewrite the Python
stack trace to point,
not to the generated code
line that has an error,
but to the line of code
that you actually wrote.
So that you can connect your
actions with their consequences
instead of having this
black box that deals with.
And if you've used
TensorFlow, and you've
seen the errors at runtime--
we already show you
two stack traces,
one for when the graph is
built and another one for when
the session.run was called.
And in principal, we can also
rewrite the stack traces here,
so that the graph with
build stack trace shows
the code you wrote, not the
code AutoGraph generated.
And we're working on
making this happen.
So what's in the
future of AutoGraph?
We have a public beta.
It's in tf.contrib.autograph.
We encourage you to try it.
It's ready to use.
If you find a bug-- and I hope
you don't-- but if you find
a bug, file something on GitHub.
Let's work with us to get a fix.
You might have seen that
we are starting to announce
a lot of our plans for TF 2.0.
And one of our big
things in TF 2.0
is that eager execution is
going to be enabled by default.
And to make crossing the
bridge between eager execution
and graph deployability
easier, AutoGraph
will be a key part of this.
So we would love to get this
tested as much as we possibly
can before TF 2.0 comes.
Meanwhile, we're working on
improving our handling-- yes--
but also, enhancing our
coverage of the Python language,
adding more and more
and more operations
to what AutoGraph
supports, so that you
have to think less
and less and less
about how your code is going
to be turned into a graph
and more about, what do
you actually want your code
to do in the first place?
We also want to factor out the
source code transformation bit
into its own library, so that
if you have some Python project
where you want to
override _ _if_ _,
you will be able to reuse
their code to do that.
Because it's a pretty neat,
self-contained little thing
that I think can
be useful broadly,
beyond the TensorFlow universe.
So thank you for
listening to me.
But if-- strongly encourage
you to go open your laptops
and do this.
Google autograph collab, and
click on the first result.
Or open this link here.
This will point
you to a notebook
that's hosted on
Google infrastructure.
So you can use
our GPUs for free.
And it has lots of little
examples for how-- like,
this is code before AutoGraph.
This is code after AutoGraph.
This is what an
error looks like.
These are things we can do.
And I think playing around with
this can really help give you
an idea that's a lot
more concrete than what
I've been talking about.
What are the actual
capabilities of this technology?
And I'm sure if you try
this, you'll have a blast.
Thank you.
Oh, also, Frank and I are
going to be at the TensorFlow
booth in the sponsor area if
you have any questions, even
if you don't want ask them now.
OK.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]